Ryan Reynolds here and I'm gonna be
playing a little thing called snack wash
from the mattifying Bowl let's open it
up oh geez that lost already
I'm not one to judge a book by it's
cover but I'm not reading it this is
this is Meat Loaf is a just that's a
British bondage that's very good let it
up a little little little I mean it's
fine it's fine
that and this like Sigourney Weaver like
delivered death it's made out of the
bowels of a sheep or something like that
and it's all wrapped up in the slider of
a pig give you a whole bladder all to
yourself oh yeah
if you call it a bladder and it's on a
plate it loss it's not boring it's not
boring I'm gonna I'm gonna eat the
bladder and everything
there's no bowel like that at all
now let's roll all night it turns me
life is boring I love that bad I'm not
gonna be able to eat my lunch now that
I've been there Oh mr. Porky's crispy
strips the lighter porky snack they both
look terrifying
it's just pork skin fried yeah you know
what a gift thank you
oh I can't oh my god people eat this
time so you have to get drunk to you
makes sense I can't I can't
the smell is enough yeah I mean this is
it's a sugary meaty snack what's not
like round two okay yeah Kendal mint
cake versus Cornish ice cream hold on
it's not ice cream
it's Eton Mess how versus it's a mess
it's a mess
do you know the story about Kendal mint
kids anything new - no it's people take
them when they're hiking because it's
very high in calories so if you are ever
lost it's good snack knowledge guys Oh
lynchin refreshing it's okay is this is
this supposed to be like that or is it
it's gonna be it we've got very gleeful
don't you might have meringue in here
there is tiny tiny tiny pieces in the
round I mean I mean I mean I thought it
had supposed to go for that I mean if I
was dog walking and I got lost you love
a dog look I love a dog walk yeah it's a
bit as he's home always away a dog in a
way he's a big love a bit of dog in
Britain where before we before your
lover I am rude I don't know what that
is some Scottish I believe I know what I
am very taste like
no I probably have iron bread because
the parties made from girders I mean I
prefer this no this you yeah yes this
stop is a bit of mate no what did you
call it as a kid I am broke
I'm saying I am bring this no it's
called earn brew do all right there's no
one I used to always call it I am brave
my mind is born
I've never been great did not have you
spot brew correctly
what's that grass jelly deep chunk let
me try the little smell like nothing a
moment the thing I do like it is not new
yours can't be anything bug from New
York
the coming years Cheers
tell you what that's all right the one
thing you might find a bit odd when
you're drinking it liquid comes to your
mouth but the cam feels heavy like
there's something else in there I think
I'm the bottom it's like really every
widget it's something heavy in the non
pleasant no he's still at the grass
jelly drink oh really I want some ham
[Laughter]
I have never seen that done in my life
squat was behind us
that is right well all right us let's
put it out someone's gonna lose an eye
in your hands everything is a weapon
right nobody's away yet Yeah right now
it's toxic waste no idea what do you
think oh good I'll take it
it's sour tell you I can observe in
Austria I like it I like it a lot better
than pets no I do okay so it's a toss-up
Tiffani I know what that is this here
ain't none of us um got me a roach
banner hey I had it before
Oh God Oh God yes I told you were their
fellow it tastes like bad breath and
medications yeah I don't know why would
they do that the kids here's your lunch
little wal Z like okay what do I have
mom I'm about some Vegemite on some
white bread it's the peanut butter and
jelly where's that one bye voila Oh
plexy British I don't know she just
threw that to one side like morning that
we have good in jacking duck
I think it's from Russia oh okay maybe I
just not trust do you like quality and
if you do do you have a favor
I definitely have a favorite and I just
I'll just give it a rest give me the
purple one
yes see I knew are the purple one it's
the best that's got a big knot in it and
I like nuts like a plastic log oh my god
this looks good you think they're
different flavors oh no I'm not about
dark chakra why is it Gary
no I'm not about this you play as one
all the way you can't be a classic
quality straight gentleman's relish I'll
say this before looks like a job for me
gentleman's relish relish oh my god so
I've never had gentleman's relish people
yeah yeah delicious on hot toast silly
I'm not hot toast well oh yeah is as
well oh that's nice we need some bread
you got any bread
oh good lord is so salty use sparingly
it says positive dinner that was wrong
fish goats or something like oh my god
open this can see like if I see
something my best friend eat trying to
be healthy and everything
oh let macro who's the better one yeah I
know this Sokka Sokka thought the
doctors get it from bean oh yeah how
could that possibly
you know what is missing guys with cream
bit socket or day is image lock thinking
on my team here yeah wow there's a whole
different ball thing I'm in Vienna
Austria is without any doubt the winner
of this one I have to thank you ready
playing saw that white cage don't make
my Bible has always fun don't know is
great experience I like this one so much
thank you it's very nerve-wracking
honestly eight in front of a load of
people Oh fingers
[Music]